hi everyone this is Professor in dust
science and this video is part of our
series on math for Science and
Engineering this video covers the
differential equation for concentric
circles which is an example of a
separable differential equation so if
you haven't done it yet make sure that
you check out the video where we explain
how to solve a general example of the
family of separable differential
equations and otherwise let's go in this
video we're going to go through an
example of a separable first order
ordinary differential equation you
should be familiar with separable first
order Odes and the general techniques to
solving them that we discuss in the
corresponding video if that's not the
case please pause here and go back to it
there's really no rush and it is better
to make sure that all the concepts are
very clear in this video we will focus
on solving a particular example we will
solve the equation x + y * Dy by DX
equals
z the first thing to note is that you
will often encounter equations written
in different ways in the video
discussing the general solution to these
equations we wrote them in this standard
form in which the differential is on the
left hand side and the rest is on the
right hand side in our case the equation
as written doesn't have this form so the
first step is to figure out whether it
can be Rewritten in the standard form so
that we can then confirm that we are
indeed dealing with a separable
equation to do so we first copy down the
equation that we've been
given and we then rewrite it by moving
the X term to the right hand side and we
finally isolate the derivative by moving
the Y term dividing to the right hand
side by inspection we now see that this
equation does indeed have a separable
form but to make this more concrete we
can compare it to the standard form
that's right up here and we can identify
the function f ofx as equal to Min - x
and the function G of Y Asal to 1 / Y
and in fact this identification is not
unique and we could also choose f ofx as
equal to X and G of Y as equal to - 1 /
y but either way the equation that we
have today is clearly of separable form
and so moving forward we will use this
standard form
here great so let's now solve this
equation we will use the standard
algebraic trick for separable equations
and let's start by by copying down the E
equation again so we have it right here
remember that the algebraic trick is to
consider the derivative Dy by DX as a
standard ratio of the quantity dy over
the quantity DX and if we do that we
will be able to manipulate this
expression such that we move all
quantities that depend on y to the left
hand side and all of the quantities that
depend on X to the right hand side site
and I'm leaving some spaces to
facilitate the next
step this next step is to integrate the
left hand side with respect to Y and the
right hand side with respect to X these
integrals are standard integrals which
you will have encountered before and for
the left integral we get 12 y^2 and
don't forget the integration constant
C1 and on the right we get 1 12
x^2 with its corresponding integration
constant
C2 bringing everything together we get
12 y^2 = - 12 x^2 + C where I've
combined the two integration constants
into
one and that's it we can now rewrite
this Solution by multiplying through by
2 to get y^2 = - x^2 + 2 C
and we can finally calculate the square
root to get y as equal to plusus the
square Ro T of - x^2 + 2
C and this is the solution to our
differential
equation in summary we've now solved
this differential equation and found
that the solution takes this
form whenever we find a solution to a
differential equation we can always
check that we have the correct Solution
by inserting it back into the equation
and confirming that the equation is
indeed satisfied so let's try that with
our equation our proposed solution is y
= + - < TK - x^2 + 2 C so to confirm
that this is a valid solution we can
evaluate the derivative of y and if we
do that explicitly we get the Der ative
with respect to X of this expression
where I am rewriting the square root as
the power 12 for
Simplicity to evaluate this derivative
we first write the plus minus in front
and next we use the standard derivative
of a power to get 1/2 time the argument
of the
power and then the power decreases by
one so we get a power of
min-2 and finally you using the chain
rule we need to differentiate the
argument of the power which in this case
is -
2x and feel free to pause here for a
moment to convince yourself of this
derivative and all of its multiple
steps moving on this factor of two
cancels out with this other factor of
two and we can reorganize the resulting
expression like this where I'm
transforming back from the power of
minus one2 to 1/ a square Ro T and it is
now clear that this denominator here is
equal to the solution y so we end up
with - x over Y and therefore we find
that the derivative of our proposed
solution is indeed equal to - x over Y
and this is the equation that we started
with up here and that confirms that our
solution is
correct
as a final step it's always good
practice to make a graph of the solution
to a differential equation as it may
reveal some interesting features that
may not be fully Apparent from the
mathematical
expression however before we do that we
will rewrite the solution in a form that
makes it easier for us to draw so
starting with a form of the solution up
here we can square both sides to end up
with this new equation
and in fact you will recognize this as
an equation that we already had as we
were solving the differential equation
before we fully isolated y we can
rewrite it further as x^2 + y^2 = 2 C
and finally let's define a new constant
a as equal to the square < TK of 2 C so
that we could reite the equation as x^2
+ y^2 = a 2 and I imagine many of you
will now recognize this equation it is
indeed the equation of a circle of
radius a and Center at the
origin for every different choice of
integration constant a we will get a
circle of a different radius and
therefore the solutions to our original
equation form the family of all possible
circles centered at the origin or to put
it another way this differential
equation up here describes the family of
all circles centered at the
origin and we can plot a representative
subset of the family of solutions of our
differential equation and we will do
that on this pair of
axes this solution in blue corresponds
to AAL 1 which is a circle of unit
radius for larger values of a we get get
the circles shown in green which have
larger
radi and for smaller values of a we get
the circles shown in red orange which
have smaller radi and overall any of
these circles is a valid solution to the
differential equation that we've solved
in this
video remember that you can find other
examples of separable differential
equations in the links that we've got in
the description I hope you liked the
video and please
subscribe